jetzt also scholz in new york city und
das hat einen ernsten und wichtigen
hintergrund natürlich den ukraine krieg
die erste rede des kanzlers vor der
vollversammlung der vereinten nationen
riesiges interesse gab es allerdings das
muss man schon ehrlich sagen weltweit
nicht an dieser rede leere stuhlreihen
dort in der uno vollversammlung als der
kanzler klare worte versuchte an putin
zu senden
deshalb dürfen wir nicht die hände in
den schoß legen wenn eine hochgerüstete
nukleare großmacht noch dazu ein
gründungsmitglied der vereinten nationen
und ständiges mitglied des un
sicherheitsrates grenzen mit gewalt
verschieben will
russlands eroberungskrieg gegen die
ukraine ist durch nichts zu
rechtfertigen präsident putin führt ihn
mit einem einzigen ziel sich der ukraine
zu bemächtigen
selbstbestimmung und politische
unabhängigkeit zählen für ihn nicht
dafür gibt es nur ein wort das ist
blanker imperialismus
dass die worte also des kanzlers dort in
new york vor der uno-vollversammlung
unser bild us korrespondent herbert
bauernebel in new york größe dich
herbert wir haben gerade die leeren
stuhlreihen noch mal gesehen da in der
vollversammlung also nimmt amerika nimmt
das die welt überhaupt wahr wenn unser
kanzler da jetzt zum ersten mal new york
ist und zur welt spricht
die primetime weniger gut für die un
hauptsitz haben dort viele diplomaten
hier bereits zum abendessen gegangen
sind deshalb auch diese etwas leerer
halle aber natürlich das ist weniger
wichtig als die worte von bundeskanzler
olaf scholz der hier ganz mit den worten
einfach ja die aggression von kreml
despoten wladimir putin angeprangert hat
von imperialismus gesprochen hat viele
richtige worte benutzt hat um das war
natürlich für ihn eine gelegenheit hier
doch wieder flagge zu zeigen leere ränge
oder nicht die un-vollversammlung ist
der größte diplomatische events des
jahres mit 190 nationen anwesen das ist
die weltbühne und die hat olaf scholz
führt bei dieser rede relativ effektiv
genutzt ob es eine imagekorrektur geben
kann da deutschland wird er von vielen
westlichen alliierten er als zauderer
hier angesehen in der ukraine politik
das bleibt abzuwarten
ja klare worte an putin der will er
jetzt blitzschnell volksabstimmung
durchführen in einigen regionen der
ukraine um sich diese regionen im ganz
schnell unter nagel zu reißen auch dazu
hat sich scholz geäußert
ja er sprach von shine referenten die
hier abgehalten werden im osten der
ukraine in lohans kommt
eine weitere region das wurde da gab es
eine klare absage natürlich vom
deutschen kanzler wie auch allen anderen
westlichen alliierten die sind sich
einig hier in dieser frage man möchte
auch hier bei dieser un-vollversammlung
einfach zeigen dass man zusammenhält
angeführt von den amerikanern aber auch
viele westliche verbündete die hier
zusammen stehen um zusammengestanden
sind bisher bei der unterstützung der
ukraine und das auch das ist ein
wichtiges signal bei dieser heurigen
aber diese diesjährigen
uno-vollversammlung unser kanzler zum
ersten mal in new york und dabei unser
us korrespondent herbert bauernebel
danke dir
[Musik]